[Music]
good morning John it's Monday November
12th today is an important day no it
isn't it's a not an important day at all
and I don't know what to talk about I
have a kitty though is he cutie
transfixed I could walk you through what
has been done so far in the scavenger
hunt I'm only able to confess Lee
conveyed this because of the hard work
of PK Iverson in my pants glue one was
pretty simple
John hid a dollar bill that had words on
it a subway in Indianapolis the words
were all anagrams of the first of many
which it has turned out to be clue
number two was under a rock in Englewood
Florida someone drove a very long time
to get to this one and I would like to
thank them for not letting it just sit
there and without a rock that would have
been head of a set into the scavenger
hunt you nerdfighters figure out that
the phrase on the one dollar bill oh um
Harry Potter fan anagrams - the
four-part harmony which led them to a
video in which I perform a four-part
harmony with three of my friends this
song is called will you miss me when I'm
gone from your pants that video and
YouTube had a comment from never FTB a
never FTB a had a video posted on his
account of the yeti talking about where
the next clue was hidden on the ninth
floor of a hotel on top of a soda
machine and somebody wasn't found it
that note was to Curt P Peter if you say
it fast it's Kurt P Peter and the note
had an anagram on it ad wheezy weirdos
which anagrams - why do we a doors a the
next clue said up in one of my videos
and once I gave you five anagrams those
phrases anagrams to Seattle i'ts
Harrison sleeps on Capitol Hill under
left shoulder you'll find a bill which
led some Seattle nerdfighters do the
next clue a dollar bill under the
shoulder of a statue of sleeping
homeless man which contained nothing
more than the phrase barf event barf
event does anagram - never have TV a but
instead of anagram in it the cover
nerdfighters went to youtube.com slash
barf event and found the next clue which
was in fact a collection of ones and
zeros that when converted from binary
translates to a headless cash bus which
of course is an anagram
that translates to because he had class
the next school is so extremely
complicated and cool that I can't even
explain it to you you
to go to the thread that I've posted in
one of these places and look for Kluber
6qu number six okay
blew my mind and that crazy clue led
nerdfighters to find another clue taped
to the bottom of a DHL box in Santa
Monica California bag clue contained a
random string of letters which the
nerdfighters then discovered was
actually a blog at blogspot.com that
blog had a summary of scavenger hunt
events and a new clue that clue was 24.1
2.19 bat main well somebody figured it
out in the first month of brotherhood
2.0 on the 24th day at time signature
219 John discusses a book that book is
the Second Coming by Walter Percy in
that video John also talks about how he
was visiting store managers from the
Bortas bookstore chain with another
deftly left hint John indicates a
Borders bookstore in Chicago near a
water tower nerdfighters found a dollar
bill inside the Second Coming by Walker
Percy in that borders in Chicago on that
dollar bill was an uncomfortably
difficult mathematical equation that
Wynn solved gave the answer 366 now what
does that mean and finally for the most
recent clue this weekend I left a post
in the brother to.com forum with the
title the clue is hidden at brother head
to comm clever nerdfighters took very
little time realizing that the clue was
in fact hidden that Brotherhood to.com
emailed that email address and any
nerdfighter who emails hidden the
Brotherhood to comm receives an email
with a URL in it and that URL contains a
scan of a dollar bill and that dollar
bill contained an anagram that anagrams
- but what is class and now we've got
too caught up but what's the next clue
well it's another Internet only clue so
everybody can start trying to find it
right now that clue is okay she didn't
think it was gonna be that easy did you
if you look for it you'll find it John
I'll see you tomorrow